as some of you noticed if I saw this
slot from Friday to today of calamities
broke his toe so he'll speak on Friday
one more scheduled change but today and
it will never know couldn't come for
some family emergency and so on up on
both sides between a talk at 11:30 in
place over a nickel and we figure out a
schedule change later on on Wednesday
morning more on film and stock replaced
by a new book binder on the same roughly
the same area and those of the three
changes so far and tomorrow evening from
4:30 to 5:30 we are planning on having a
some lightning quick talks for seven
minutes if you're interested in giving
such a talk on open problem or a short
result that you want to highlight please
send an email to the organizers myself
is my email address will be check for
yet Illinois I don't need you or a gmail
that's it for now I'm gonna thank
silence to tells the Sinclair staff
Peter Barton is taken over from Alistair
and first talk today is by Posada
Ragavendra on the power of sum of
squares for plantain problems thank you
thank you for the invitation to speak
here and thanks for coming out this
early in the morning on the first day I
barely made it so here so today I'll
talk about the power of sum of squares
for detecting hidden structures and this
is joint work with Sam Hopkins pravesh
Qatari iron protection sling SRAM I
think who's here and David starter so so
although we will be talking about sum of
squares the main result will be about
sum of squares and it will be about
hidden structures you know the sort of
the theme which I like about this work
is a really slightly more broad so
here's a linear program and we all of
you might recognize immediately that
this is a linear program for the maximum
clique in a graph okay this is a linear
program for a maximum clique and so when
we want to understand the approximation
given by this linear program the natural
lower bound technique is to produce oh
sorry I meant maximum independent set
yeah thanks okay so this is a maximum
independent set and when you want to
understand the approximation given by
this program the natural way to prove a
lower bound would be two would be to
construct an independent Agrella Gap
instance and what would an integrity gap
instance be that would just be you know
you know I guess at the C the first cat
would for example you could pick a
triangle and show that the value of the
LP is three halves whereas the optimal
solution is only a 1 so that gives a gap
between the linear programming optimal
and the optimal solution for the graph
now this is a well you know this is a
lower bound but it is always a little
bit unsatisfactory when I you know at
first because you know in some sense if
you run the routing algorithm on the
integrality gap instance you get a very
good approximation much better than the
one given here so in terms of rounding
it's not really a gap because because
because there is a gap between the LP
and opt the loss incurred by the
rounding is actually makes it comparable
to opt so in so in that sense it's not a
hard instance and moreover an obvious
quip could be hey this
just one instance how hard can it be you
know let's just add a condition in our
algorithm say if you see a triangle
output 1 so really when we want to say
that this problem is hard what we really
want is a distribution or instances
where a distribution over not just one
instance but probably many many
instances and ideally distribution over
instances all of which exhibit this sort
of a gap between the LP and opt and even
even that is actually not concrete
evidence like in the concrete
experimental level if you want to do
concrete experimental evidence that the
problem is hard if you if I just gave
you a distribution of integral to gap
instances it's somewhat unsatisfactory
because maybe someone could quit maybe
there is some pattern among these this
distribution of instances which we don't
see but if you if somebody who sees this
pattern maybe this sum of the degrees of
the first second and third vertex
actually tells you that it is from this
distribution and that gives you an opera
on top so therefore what you know what
we what would really make it a
satisfactory lower bound would be if you
had a pair of distributions of instances
which have different values for magazine
click and they are somehow
computationally indistinguishable in you
know in all the ways that we try so and
you know this is not a new concept
you know it's fairly well known so for
instance think this is a very natural
distribution or instances so you have
new distributions for the maximum clique
or a sorry maximum depend set I think I
switch click here yeah it's a click so
the maximum clique problem on one in one
distribution you just so this is the no
case in the low case the the graph just
looks like a random GN half graph
every I just included property half and
we know that the clique size or
independent order login with very high
probability the opt is order log n over
here and another distribution which is
essentially you sample a random graph of
with GN half and then you include a
clique of size K into it so this is a
yes case so this is just you have G and
half
sample Gian half and pick a random
subset of size K inside it and you
include all the edges inside s into the
graph so make make s a clique so this is
another graph now this gives you two
distributions over instances and the
nice thing right now is that these
distributions seem to give some you know
concrete you know experimental evidence
you could say of the fact that clique is
hard I mean of course there's much
stronger evidence which you know but why
am I looking at this but my can
construct much harder distributions
which are indistinguishable for clique
but this just is a very simple example
of two distributions which we know and
we expect to be computationally
indistinguishable in the sense that you
know it's not just about LPS or SD peas
we expect that or if you take the
degrees of these vertices in the graph
and you compute the parity of all the
degrees which they should be similar and
so on although we don't know how to grow
all these facts we expect these to be
true and so this would be a nice sort of
starting point for integrity gaps or
lower bounds for problems two
distributions which are
indistinguishable and so and this is
again not new there's a lot of work on
LP and SDP lower bounds for plan
technique problem but one thing that was
always a little bit disappointing was
that we always had the following issue
that okay if you want to prove that
let's say linear programs let's say
linear programming hierarchy doesn't
solve this this cannot distinguish
between these two distributions the way
we would go about proving that is we
would prove that the no case is and
distribution of integrity gap instances
meaning we would prove prove it the
following way
we would say pick
random graph G from the know case which
is just the uniform distribution over
all graphs and then this is a no case
and then we would like to prove that the
LP well let's say the SD p value in this
case is high we'd like to prove that is
DP optimum SD p opt of G is large let's
say it's much larger than log n ok and
then the strategy would be okay now we
have a random graph and let's just
construct feasible solutions for the SDP
for this graph construct a feasible
solution
for the STP okay this would be the
approach now for this graph for G okay
and this would be extremely subtle you
know because the SDP has many SDP or the
linear program has several equality
constraints several inequality
constraints and many many different
constraints that we would like to
satisfy in order for the solution to be
feasible and but now we just have this
one fixed random graph we are working
with we just got one random graph and we
need to construct this feasible solution
for the SDP and this exercise would be a
little bit tricky but moreover what
would be disappointing about it is we
started with this situation where we
were interested in whether we can
distinguish between these two
distributions and this was a sort of our
beginning evidence that these two this
problem is hard but right now we have
thrown out all of any information about
the planted distribution right right now
our problem is we just got a random
graph and we would like to construct a
feasible solution for the SDP or LP so
this you know it's it it's a the the key
disappointing fact about this is that
the planted distribution that
indistinguishability of the planted
distribution uniform distribution okay
cannot be exploited in this strategy yet
because we just got a random graph and
we need to construct the HP solution and
so this is what was what was basically
the approach towards many of these low
lower bounds until this recent beautiful
work by some of the some of our quarters
and others it's Barak Hopkins Kellner
Hari
maire and petition
so they approved essentially a login
round integrality gap for SOS SOS
integrate a gap for planted leak
but the when I guess the from me the
most important idea which they came up
with is this thing which they call
pseudo calibration
and this is a very pseudo calibration
this is a very beautiful idea it's in
login rounds you cannot get n to the 1/2
minus epsilon yes and no no in the sense
that unlike Louis reiver and some other
hierarchies the degree degree D sum of
squares hierarchy is fairly canonical in
the sense that it doesn't really matter
what particular set of polynomial
equalities you started with for most
problems I mean I'm in the sensory a the
degree D sum of squares hierarchy for
instance for planted clique would
include every degree D inequality that
is or equality so every degree D
equality that you could add you could
have added initially so in the sense
that it doesn't unlike in case of Louis
Eyer it was true that it really mattered
what original prop Rob relaxation
started with and you lift it but here it
really almost doesn't matter in the
following sense that there is no degree
D inequality or say degree D equality
that I think is true for integral
solutions that you could add for
practically
or here yes it does sorry I was being
with little bit so let's say you know
for plan to click for k equal to n to
the 1/2 minus Epsilon okay this is a
very this is for a very explicit program
so I should I mean I shouldn't oversell
it this really just for you take the
explicit program which is a degree D a
source for axial uprightly they prove
lower bound for it it's not an a it's
not a relaxing it's not a lower bound
for general algorithms in any sense yes
yes no no sorry yeah maybe I'm over
something what I'm saying all I'm saying
is that we we experimentally believe
that these two distributions are
computationally indexing sharable and
that should be useful in proving a spare
lower bound for a specific algorithm and
this wasn't done earlier before this
work every lower bound proof went in
this direction where you just pick a
random graph and try to prove that
there's a feasible solution which means
that you throw away the planted click
distribution completely to the side and
then so the the computational difficulty
of distinguishing between the two
distributions doesn't show up in the
proof of the lower bound at all whereas
over here
the proof of the lower bound actually
uses the planted distribution explicitly
which is the which is the key thing
which I'm trying to emphasize it's not
that yeah this is not a lower bound
against general algorithms I'm just
saying that you can yeah
so yes yes I will explain how accuse us
yeah yes okay so so this is a this is
idea and we'll come to come back to this
I'll explain what sort of calibration is
a little bit later but you know now that
we are thinking about distinguishing
between two distributions as I said this
gives you a different way to look at LPS
DP lower bounds right so in particular
so here's a situation so we have two
distributions one is the planted and the
uniform you have two distributions so we
could for example decide decide to look
at in some fixed distinguisher let's say
the degree of a vertex okay degree of a
vertex and then you could look at this
is some function let's say D this is a
function and then we would like to look
at its expectation under the planted
description which I'll call mu in the
stock degree of a vertex or under the
uniform distribution which I'll call new
and then you could wonder if the two are
comparable and of course if the problem
is computationally hard these two should
be comparable okay so this is a very
simple distribution we can go further
you could say let's just look at lower
degree polynomials so what what do I
mean by low degree polynomial here I
mean low degree polynomial in the edges
of the graph for example you could count
the number of triangles in the graph the
number of triangles in the graph is a
degree 3 polynomial in the edges of the
graph right so and then you could wonder
if the expectations of those quantities
are similar so let's say the low degree
polynomial P of G
the GE sample from you and then you
could try to prove that these two are
comparable to each other and you know if
this is a game we could keep playing in
the sense that you could look at
stronger and stronger distinguished
ships and then in each of those
distinguisher we could try to prove that
the expected value in one case is equal
to the expected value in the other case
this is a very natural approach and then
you know you would have you know let's
say d round sherilee Adams LP here okay
and then you would you really want to
prove a proving a lower bound would
amount to showing that the d round sorry
items LP in at least an expectation is
equal to the d round Charolais adams LP
for the other for the two distributions
okay or equal to d round sum of squares
SDP
degree decimal squares as DP I will
define what degree D sum of squares as
debase soon but for now just take it as
an algorithm which outputs a number and
so so you see that if you want to prove
we could we could just look at our
betrays class of distinguishes and try
to prove that their expectations in the
two cases are equal and so expectations
I guess the simple thing to look at
ideally you would want something in
probability yes it is right that well
you know it's not sufficient that these
two are equal and expectation ideally
you'd want also want to prove that in
probability the the distributions look
the same maybe it is the case that if
you look at the SOS value of degree D
SOS value it's an even number whenever
it's a planet like it's an odd number
whenever X uniform then you serve you
really aren't distributions but for now
let's let's say this I mean 1+1 by Polly
1 1 by for the factors 1 plus 1 by Polly
factors so okay so what what's the point
of doing this well so actually let me
add so what's the point of doing this
the point is maybe you don't want to
think about s irelia x LP or there so
SSDP let's just think about
distinguishes which are general
functions and let's try to prove these
indistinguishability facts for stronger
and stronger class of distinguishers and
at some point this distinguishes are so
strong that they immediately imply
surely atoms are sstp so in particular
so in sometimes the main result of the
our work is the following which I'll
state formally later but just to give
give you preview so so look at the
following distinguished types of
distinguisher so you compute so this is
called low-degree matrix distinguisher
so the idea here is you compute
polynomial P which is a low degree
polynomial but it outputs a matrix so
every entry of this matrix so it's a low
degree matrix polynomial so every entry
of this matrix is a low degree
polynomial in the graphs for example
this could just be let's say you have a
one row for every pair IJ one column for
every pair KL and then you put a one
there if I J and K L form a bipartite
clique right so something basically any
for any matrix function whose entries
are low degree polynomials in graph so
you compute this and then you compute
be some polynomial decent polynomial
size see computer this is I'm describing
a class of distinguisher so here's a
class here's a grape type of algorithm
you could try you compute a low degree
polynomial matrix of the graph and then
you compute its largest eigenvalue okay
this is an algorithm that you could just
compute its largest eigenvalue meaning
you output lambda max the largest
eigenvalue of this polynomial of this
matrix okay so now this is a very simple
algorithm we will call this low degree
spectral distinguisher okay and
essentially our our main result is that
low degree spectral distinguishers are
as powerful as degree DSO SSDP four
broad classes of problems what that
means is that if you are trying to run
an algorithm for this distributional
problems in many cases if your SOS SDP
works there's a underlying low degree
algorithm which just computes a matrix
and compress the largest eigenvalue it's
a much easier task and solve SDP which
will also distinguish the two in the
sense of expectation not in the sense of
probability the other direction is if
you are trying to prove a lower bound
all you would want to do is to prove
that low degree matrix distinguishes
don't distinguish between the two
distributions
yeah but but we use a fixed graph in the
sense that there's no it's really like
the algorithm takes the graph as input
so it's not statistical in the sense
that yeah you need the specific matrix
to compute the actually yeah that's one
connection which I haven't explored here
which is we see these things do seem
related to statistical algorithms and I
am cheating a little bit here actually
lambda max is not lambda max its lambda
max plus so what is lambda max plus that
is max of lambda Max and zero
BFG but this is essentially the result
but I will describe it in greater detail
but I did
I
the reason I really like this kind of a
presentation is that when you state the
problem as trying to come up with a
solution for a particular graph the
problem becomes very hairy with all
sorts of equality constraints that you
need to satisfy and a very hairy problem
with you know we do not construct this
thing whereas when we state the problem
as there are two distributions and you'd
like to prove that a function like this
has the same expectation under the two
distributions this seems more well
studied a little bit more well said in
the sense that this is essentially what
happens in a lot of pseudo randomness
work then you say suit bounded
independence fools half-spaces
what they're proving is we take the
uniform distribution you prove take a
distribution which is boundary
independent and then you take your
function to be a half space the
expectation the true distribution is the
same and if we if one could do such
things for functions which are like this
which are spectral that would be
fantastic because then that would be
give you a more cleaner way to get all
of these lower bounds given this result
okay many of the result you get with
respect I essentially couldn't prove it
I said if I have time we will see a
sketch of the proof but I'll state the
theorem I state the theorem in more
detail yeah sorry about yeah
yes yes so it is a little bit yeah it's
a little bit statistical in the sense
that the - you know we are just claimed
that the expectation of the two sdp
values are the same but and but you if
you really want to prove that they're in
this you show you would want some sort
of high probability statement but you
know in some cases you can get this just
by Markov inequality for example if you
are interested in planted click if you
prove that the expectation of the SSD
p-value is root n then with at least one
over poly probability it's at least some
so in that sense it's okay so so now I
want to state the result you know they
say in order to state it let me just
define some notation and so so in order
to write a resource relaxation what we
first need is a system of polynomial
equations so so for so for example if
you look at this planted clique problem
so here's the system of polynomial
equations that one would write down so
each X I this is an X I variable for
every vertex and this variable is either
we expect it to be 0 or 1 that's our
goal
so we first add a constraint which
ensures that x is 0 or 1 which is the
boolean boolean s constraint X I squared
minus X is 0 and then we want a clique
of size K therefore summation X I minus
K is equal to 0 is a constraint saying
that there's a clique of size K and then
we want it to be a clique since we want
it to be a clique whenever there is an
edge between I and J X I XJ should be so
whenever there's no edge between X I and
J x axis should be 0 so I J is not an
edge implies X I XJ is 0 now the
function the whether I J is not a by J
is an edge or not is actually a low
degree function of the graph itself if g
IJ represents
if gij is let's say plus minus one
random variable this place a plus minus
one value and such that g IJ is equal to
one if IJ is not an edge and zero
otherwise sorry minus one otherwise if
IJ is an edge then this constraint
precisely encodes the fact that whenever
there is an edge whenever there is no HX
xj0 that's this yes yes yeah thanks yeah
okay yeah yes
so but the key thing is that we have a
system of polynomial equations and each
of these equations is low degree in X
that is of course true but also a low
degree in the graph G right the as a
function of the graph G each of this
equation the coefficients and these
equations are low degree polynomials
okay so whenever we have a polynomial
system like this we can write sum of
squares SDP relaxation and the sum of
squares is the public session if you had
to state it succinctly what it does is
it tries to look for a refutation of the
system of equations so what it does is
it price look for an identity of the
following type here remember that EJ are
the equations EJ of X comma G are the
equations for any graph G and the sum of
squares as DP tries to find an identity
of this type where negative one is equal
to summation sum of squares of
polynomials plus polynomials which plus
a term which is in the ideal generated
by the edges and the entire identity
includes only the polynomials of degree
at most 2d linked with the squares yes
good points thanks yeah
so I should write I should you know
these depend on the graph but yeah these
depend on the graph essentially when you
pick a graph and run the degree DSOs
algorithm you it looks for an identity
of this type and
yes yeah in our I could have right X
comma J but I could write this as RI of
X comma G but I don't written it that
way because a prayer it's not clear that
this is a low low degree function in
graph G therefore I didn't want to
allude to that by including here here
this is clearly low degree in G but
these are arbitrary functions basically
you take the graph and solid SOS you
might get some R I function of G for
every graph G there is some Ri Ri of G
yes so in some sense every function on G
is a polynomial in Z it's a degree n
polynomial because it's just boolean
hypercube but yeah you're right that
they are not really legitimate
polynomials and since they're not low
degree or anything they're just
arbitrary functions of G ok so so now
I'm ready to state one of the key
conditions that we need in order to in
order for our claim to be true so here's
the condition it's called we call it the
robust inference property maybe there's
better name so here's the property so so
let me be a probability distribution of
0 1 to the N think of this is the MU is
the planted distribution you have a
planted distribution on 0 1 to the N
actually before going through the going
through the claim let me just say in
words what robust inference is robust
inference property is a following if you
get a sample from the planted
distribution we know that there is a
solution to the SDP or the polynomial
system but what we really want is
something stronger if I give you a
random subsample of the vertices of the
of the planted distribution even then
you just given that we should be able to
recover solution to the SDP
so
it will be very clear maybe before the
definition let me just go to the planted
click case ok what is true about the
plant leak case if I look at this
polynomial system let's say let me write
this as a summation X is equal to R X I
squared minus X I is 0 and then the
other condition if I look at this
polynomial system if I give you G from
planted planted distribution there is a
solution to this system there is obvious
but even something stronger is true if I
just gave you let's say 1/2 the vertices
of the graph G you can just looking at
those vertices construct a solution to
the system because what you what you
what you could do is you could just
output the clique vertices that you see
inside the set so here's the setup so
imagine you have this so this is the
graph G and let's say this is the clique
that we planted it's a set of size root
n yes so yes they right to the point
so suppose this set is size root n of
course that should be smaller than K
because you know we only know that is a
solution with 4 plant leaked with equal
to K and so our should be smaller than K
but let's say R is much smaller than K
for now let's say R is epsilon K let's
say R is epsilon K let's say is Delta K
okay R is Delta K okay
so here's the fact that's true if I give
you if I sub sample this graph by just
picking each vertex in in with
probability let's say 2 Delta I take
every vertex I throw it throw it out
with probability 1 minus 2 Delta I keep
it with property 2 Delta I get a subset
of the graph and this we expect will
contain some of the clique vertices and
somewhere this is outside this is a to
Delta fraction of the graph just
randomly subsampled now even just given
this random sub sample G sub s one can
construct a feasible solution for the
original polynomial system with high
probability given the just this G sub s
one can construct a feasible solution
for this polynomial system just by
because the clique will also contain
they'll be Delta fraction of the clique
also falling into this random sub sample
you just out set those x i's to one and
you get a solution to the system
no this is oh this s is the same this is
the planted dis G sub yeah sorry for
that so G sub T we sample and I'm
subsidy yes so this is just saying that
if you have planted or if you are
planted a clique then you will not you
know you'll actually see the click in
any sub sample also you don't need the
entire graph to see the flu thing okay
so this is essentially what we call
robust inference okay and so this is the
it's claims you have a planted
distribution and you have a broader
distribution or sub samplings of this
and for which is basically in our case
you just pick every vertex in with
property something and out with some
property and you we say that the
distribution satisfies robust inference
property with respect to this
subsampling if mu is epsilon robust
inferable with respect to this
subsampling if you can infer feasible
solution
to the the system to give on just the
subset okay that's
and you know this might see does seem
like a very strange condition for now
but I'll show examples to prove to you
that this is not that strange it's just
some sort of noise it's some sort of
robust inference it's just some sort of
noise so I instead of going through the
definition let me just give you a bunch
of examples yes so what do you mean a
solution for the system the system is a
pair of things you have a solution
that's the same for both
what's yes the solution to the system
for for the system is a pair of things
as H is a pair or the other so so let me
pass this so since you take a graph from
the planted distribution okay and then
you subsample the graph you subsample a
subset and then i'm allowing you to take
the rest of the graph and modify to
arbitrary anything you want and then you
get a new graph H what should be true is
that just by looking at the original
part of the graph which was left you
should be able to infer a solution to
this polynomial system for H so this is
some this robust inference property so
why is this not very strange well it's
somewhat very it's it's pretty easy to
find this robust inference property for
example suppose you wanted to prove a
lower bound for planted click sorry for
max cut let's say a linear programming
lower bound or you want to prove a lower
bound against community detection which
is stochastic block model there are two
distributions which looked like the
following in one case you just have a
uniform distribution of sparse graphs
which has sample of G n comma B or n in
the other case you have a planted
distribution which look like the
following you have two sets a and B of
equal size and there the probability of
adding an edge across is a over N the
protea tiding image inside is B minus a
over N basically the two probabilities
are different
property of Internet's interact
listening and inter-cluster Isis are
different and you would like to find out
which of the two cases it is and by
fixing a and B appropriately you can
sort of pose this as maxcut and you know
all sorts of things okay so what is the
polynomial system I am talking about
here you know you would want to pick
find a vector which is plus minus one
you would want to find a plus minus one
vector which is bit side of the
partition each vertex falls in and
system is just going to be let's say if
you know that half the vertices fall on
each side so summation X I is 0 then you
would want X I squared is 1 this is just
excise boolean and you would want the
key thing is you would want to to
correlate with the probabilities as much
as possible so we could just state this
as X transpose ax is bigger than some
quantity row where a is the adjacency
matrix
so this is the sort of polynomial system
that you would write it's just you know
already doing is you're trying to
correlate with the with the graph as
much as possible so this is a polynomial
system okay so the okay so now we need
so what are the variables now the
variables you get a graph so you see the
edges of the graph okay and what's the
subsampling that we will do so I think
the subsampling that we can do here is
essentially the same so we take but with
edges so we take every edge and then we
include it with probability 1 minus
Delta and we throw away the edge of
property Delta the subsampling is
include each edge
with probability 1 minus Delta and throw
away the edge with property Delta so
this does give you this is clearly a sub
sampling of the graph what is true about
this is that since we kept most of the
edges around because you kept 99% of the
edges around if the you will lose only a
little bit in the correlation with the
adjacency matrix if you if you were
correlating no 1 minus epsilon with the
adjacency matrix now you would correlate
1 minus epsilon minus Delta ok so you
lose a little just a little bit in the
correlation or here what that means is
when we wrote down the polynomial system
we should have put in some slack here so
that even given just the edges from the
sub sample should be able to reconstruct
a solution which is pretty good for the
entire graph so you see that this
happens here and essentially the same
kind of sub sampling can be used for
random drilling a random three-lane or
any random trillion equal to random 3
set or any CSP basically it's just the
same essentially the same idea the idea
is you have random clauses which are
appropriately chosen and then your sub
sampling is just throw away Delta
fraction of the clauses so you lose a
little bit in the value but it's still
it's still reasonable
okay so and and did serve a gender theme
this sort of happens in pencil PCA and
many other problems where you where you
have a signal which is so robust that
even a subset of their entries which
should reveal the signal
it's just that computationally it's
difficult to find a signal and this is
through intensive PCA I won't define
this problem but just I wanted to show
it for people who have seen that
okay it looks like a
it looks like I won't be able to say
much about the proof too much about the
proof but at least I will try to explain
what pseudo calibration is by the end of
the talk ok so that's the goal so now I
think we are ready to state our main
theorem so the main theorem is you have
any polynomial system which is a degree
D in the excise and degree K in the
graph degree D in the excise and degree
K in the instance you have some
polynomial system and it's very robust
so this is the probability with which
you'll fail to find a feasible solution
when you subsample so the probability we
of not finding a feasible solution
should be extremely close to one extent
because to 0 B is some number which is
just larger than D and K so just take
this to be more than 2 D K any number
which is larger than D and K and so one
property you need is that it's you can
robust linfer solutions from sub-samples
the second property you need is that you
the SOS refutations have fairly first
nicely bounded numbers so the SOS
refutation for example in planted clique
whenever there is no clique and there is
a refutation the refutation should have
numbers which are polynomially bounded
and this is something which you need to
prove in case by case but it is always
or no it's almost always very easy to
prove this fact
replication you're saying every assuming
there's an SOS definitions
okay so so so okay what is the main
theorem saying actually I should just
say it in words firstly you know it's
saying that if you have a choice refute
if a source refutes SS refutes or
distinguishes between the two
distributions then this implies that the
spectral algorithm also distinguishes
that's the claim yes
okay so the spectral algorithm also
distinguishes that's what we are
claiming so we are assuming that this is
distilled between the two and let's say
we assume if we assume a distinguish
with numbers which are bounded in this
case we can prove that there is a degree
D for degree capital d polynomial that
actually also distinguishes between the
two cases in the following sense
oh maybe it's the airplane mode it's
it's very well charged it's just it's
okay sorry I'll write on the board it's
strange I teach you this every week
twice a week and never summer in Simon's
it's always spins so this is the
statement you sample the graph from the
planted distribution and you evaluate
this function which is basically the
largest eigenvalue truncated to be
positive and look at the ratio of these
two quantities
this is a uniform distribution this is
the planted distribution there exists a
degree low degree graph loading the
matrix polynomial such that this ratio
is is very large yes well this theorem
is actually very general it applies to
all the settings that I described
earlier
so for threes you know for three lane
and it's just a say like the theorem has
no natural planted click as this is just
any polynomial system and this is just
true so in particular it also applies to
robust verifiability is just yeah it
holds for basically a yeah yeah it holds
for whenever case large yeah yeah this
is a this is a claim so then you see
that it shows that the two expectations
are very very much often to the two
distributions and
I I think we overloaded notation use D
for both in the sense that if you're
anyway solving degree D SOS SOS program
you may as well assume that you had your
original system was also degree D
because you can add every yes so here
these you could think of D as the little
D little D s so okay so what I did tell
you is how this capital D relates to
little D and that is over here
essentially you want the capital D such
that if I pick any subset of capital D
coordinates the property at all of them
fall in the subsample is very small so
that is the thing and so this clearly
differs from problem to problem in for
example in maxcut or in the community we
were throwing out every edge with
probability Delta so which means that if
you pick a subset of edges of size L
subset of L edges then the probability
that then whole thing falls inside is 1
minus Delta to the L if you keep every
edge so this is which means that you
need to pick capital D to be really
large for this ratio for this project
we're really small so it's going to be d
log n so for so for max cut and so on
for maxcut or or the community
stochastic block model or their capital
re all the CSP s capital D will be D
login so what this is saying is that if
you degree D sum of squares programs are
just as strong as polynomials of degree
D log n which that's and but if you look
at planted click there the you you know
the subsampling is very harsh
you actually can sub every vertex with
probability 1 over N to the point
Absalon you'd still have a plant clique
of size n to the 1/2 minus Epsilon if
you have started the clique of size n to
the half you kept every vertex probably
1 or n to the epsilon you still have a
clique of size over N to the 1/2 minus
Epsilon so it's very strong subsampling
in this case you know capital D will be
much smaller capital D will be
essentially be order little D so that's
yeah I'm assuming that she'll who's in
the audience will correct any mistakes
that I made so say she is quiet which
means I'm okay ok ok so I think we have
about 5 5 7 minutes I think the key
thing I will try to do is to actually
show what I promised which is pseudo
calibration to tell you what pseudo
calibration is and how our idea goes
along with that
okay so so here's a quick
so so what is Sudha calibration this is
a I think there's a very beautiful idea
when I think it you know the one way to
advertise it is it gives you a
mechanical way to construct LP and ICP
solutions for these problems once you
have the two distillation it gives you a
very mechanical approach to construct
the feasible LP STP solutions and then
of course proving it is feasible is the
tricky part but but at least gives you a
candidate solution okay so here's the
idea
so if you have mu which is a planted
distribution and call it the planted
density so mu is a function on let's say
graphs so what you have is so this is a
planted density and you know the way to
think of this is on most graphs the
planted density is 0 right mu of G is 0
on almost every graph on exponentially
small fractional graphs which are
actually coming from planted
distribution this value is really large
so that the expectation is 1 this is
just a planted density and let's say you
know you know for every graph which
comes from the planted distribution we
know what the solution is is just a
clique that we can we can out in this an
integral solution we can write down so
let's just write down that function we
call this lambda this is a function from
graphs to you could say let me just say
some high dimensional space this is just
of you know the space where the feasible
solutions live so if you have a LP it's
just a vector of all the values of the
solution and which I need SDP it's a
matrix but it really doesn't matter it's
just for every graph you want to write
down this so what is the definition of
lambda so lambda of a graph G is just if
it is not a planted
so we planted graph then you don't know
what to do we just going to output zero
zero outside new but really on Moo when
it is a planted graph it's equal to me
of G times the integral solution for G
we can actually write on an integral
solution for G it didn't have to be
integral just had to be feasible but
basically we can write down integral
solution whenever it's a blank in graph
so this gives you a function so this
gives you a function from graphs to
let's say sdp solutions and it's a very
not a useful function a priori because
whenever in on most graphs just output 0
but on planted graphs it actually
outputs the integral solution so now as
you know if you think about this graph
it's this function it's as I said you
know it's really you know on most graphs
it is 0 because it and only on the
planted grass it outputs an integral
solution and there's a large multiplier
which comes from the dismay of G which
is supposed to be like the one over the
probability that your graph is planted
okay so so far it's so fine and then
what is what a pseudo calibration do you
take this function lambda and you and
you truncate it to loading I have five
minutes so you take this function lambda
and you truncate it to degree capital D
it's the degree capaldi in G in the
graph G it has a function of the graph
it's some it was an arbitrary function
you just take it slow degree part an
alternate way to say this is you just
projecting lambda of G to the low degree
to be a low degree function so now this
is a function now it's a legitimate
function on graphs and it's not going to
be it's not going to look like this
because low degree polymers cannot look
like this it's going
look more evened out and this is the
candidate SDP solution SDP or LP
solution meaning on a random graph you
just substitute its value right
substitute a random graph here it gives
you some some matrix that matrix is
supposed to be the LPRs deep assertion
for that graph so that's a we this is
the so you see that it's completely
mechanical so far but what is the
advantage of looking at this object one
particular advantage is first of all
this you can show that this immediately
almost immediately satisfies all the
Equality constraints of the SDP and LP
although all the constraints which come
from the problem are almost already
satisfied why because lambda of G
satisfied all the Equality constraints
because it's actually a valid solution
on every graph it remains where it
outputs a solution so it's a valid
integer so it sides with all the
Equality constraints so it's very easy
to show that this object side so as most
of the annoying constraints that from
come about so the only difficult part
which we still don't know how to do very
well is to prove that this is PSD with
high probability over G this is
essentially pseudo calibration so it
gives you a mechanical way to construct
LP SDP solutions given two distributions
which is supposed to be
indistinguishable okay and now I think
in one minute what we do is one way to
say what we do is instead of taking
lambda and projecting it on to low
degree space we we take lambda which is
you know lambda is nice and PSD also
write lambda of G is PSD everywhere it's
a PSD positive semi definite matrix at
every graph just because it's a valid
solution and so lambda is appear it's
this PSD solution what we do is we just
try to find so since we go we try to
find the maximum entropy projection or
instead of just l2 projection instead of
taking lambda and just truncating all
the high degree stuff let's find a PSD
valued function which has the same low
degree properties as lambda which has
the same low degree properties as lambda
but it's as flat as possible so we have
so the idea is essentially we have this
lambda which is very spiky what we want
is another function lambda star such
that if you look at the low degree part
of lambda and lambda star they are the
same the low degree part is the same but
lambda star is has more has high maxima
has higher entropy or you could say it
has bounded to long has is more flatter
and so so that's the idea
so in matrix line it might be a little
bit more tricky but you know in case in
terms of distributions here's a way to
think of restrictions so you have the
planted distribution which is just a
function which is really spiky we asked
the question can you find a different
probability distribution on graphs which
has the same low degree properties as
the planted distribution on the low
degree function it looks the same but it
has as much as entropy as possible
meaning as has a little spike disposal
so that's a convex relaxation
finding this maximum entropy dissolution
is a convex relaxation and what we do is
we just say well if we write on the dual
of it when the relaxation has no
solution it means there's a spectral
distinguisher I'm sorry I didn't have
time to explain that very well
but be happy to explain it later that
stop here yeah can you elaborate on that
last section
you said well if there is no if you look
at it's not entropy dissipated the dual
of that is okay yes if you write if you
write on the convex program which is
fine the max entropy distribution do all
of that
exactly gives you the heebie spectral I
mean the spectral distribution what you
suggested yes do not expect the solution
at Q that I was talking about so let's
say you want to minimize subject to
lambda less than equal to D is equal to
lambda star the sleeper train even in no
degree parts are the same and am the
star is PSD if this is a convex program
you can write the dual it's going to be
a maximization problem and it's this
going to be something like find a node
degree distinct low degree matrix for
moment that correlates with the planted
distribution to much more than it does
with the uniform this equality
constraints
because then it'll be really obvious one
yes right so good but if you just really
is that these are doers of each other
but you know one mate right right that
the loading a parts are equal is to say
for every one more milk you lam lambda e
number Q it must be equal to lambda star
in a foreign key that's the same as
writing that the loading requires a
little put now it's clear that you know
if there is no solution to this program
there should be some queue which
actually distinguish between the two and
that queue will be the way to solution
so it's really serious those zeros over
that this is just once I found through
the completion then you're now in there
to do anything okay
yeah I think zero is somehow because if
you just look at John any clear message
you want it to look like energy like
let's say in the SDP solution for
instance there is one inch which
corresponds to one right and just like
and that should yes it should look like
like a density so if you put other
things then this won't look like the
density anymore
it's a zero important because like we've
been taking loading the projection of
this matrix and so if you put other
things and this loading intersection be
different